[Musik]
hallöchen den lieben wir machen heute
eine richtig erfrischende einfache aber
unfassbar leckere choco fresh torte und
zwar habe ich mir überlegt dadurch dass
auch der wunsch total oft kam und ich
auch choco fresh persönlich total gerne
mag überlege ich mir wirklich so die
ultimativen objekt ort aktiv vor ort
ausprobiert und ich mache jetzt ein
zweites mal und film das ganze und
wünsche euch eine freude beim nachmachen
wenn ihr meinen kanal noch nicht
abonniert habe dann holt es jetzt nach
und aktiviert die glocke dann werdet ihr
benachrichtigt wenn es ein neues video
gibt im choco fresh ist ja vor allem
enthalten vollmilchschokolade milch und
haselnuss creme und ich habe mir diese
drei komponenten einfach mal zum anlass
genommen was schönes und leckeres zu
entwickeln aber wir brauchen jetzt kurz
einmal eine vorbereitung was unseren
tortenring angeht
zu den tortenring habe ich auf 24
zentimeter durchmesser eingestellt und
ihr könnt jetzt auch ein backpapier
nehmen ich habe eigentlich augen
backpapier es ist so weiß nicht wundern
ich schlag das jetzt einfach eine mit
die zugleich einfache habe mit dem
transport und blickt dann noch ein
torten retter und runter und dann geht's
schon direkt an die zubereitung für den
boden vorab dass es kein kooperations
video auch wenn es vielleicht so
rüberkommt weil die marke erwähnt wird
für meinen boden brauchen wir erstmal
einen mixer wenn ihr kein mixa da habt
dann tut alles in einen gefrierbeutel
und geht wie moodle häusler bis es schön
fein ist und die butterkekse werden
jetzt erstmal schön fein gemahlen und
danach gebe ich haselnuss kerne gehackte
und haselnuss krokant mit rein
ich fand die kombination einfach richtig
richtig gut wenn jetzt noch kein
haselnuss krokant habt könnt ihr auch
komplett haselnuss kernen auch voris
gerne mal nach meiner art und weise aus
denn mich würde mal interessieren wie
euch das rezept dann schmeckt wenn es
nach macht
so die butterkekse gebe ich jetzt in
einer schüssel und nachdem wir dann auch
die haselnuss kern und den haselnuss co
kann dazu gegeben habt könnt ihr schon
mal verrühren und auch schon
geschmolzene butter dazugeben
die geschmolzene butter redet aber für
die bindung nicht ausreichen denn jetzt
kommt noch mein lieblingszitat rein und
zwar ist das meine haselnuss creme denn
auch in choco fresh ist haselnuss creme
drin und ich habe diesen boden so noch
nie gemacht hätte es für dieses rezept
das erste mal halt experimentiert und
ausprobiert und das war so ein highlight
also es so unfassbar leckerbissen ich
mal ausprobieren
die haselnuss creme wenn sie heute ist
es relativ warm dann ist sie sehr cremig
wenn ihr sie in den kühlschrank
aufbewahrt ist er so ein bisschen fester
aber ihr dürft die haselnuss creme auch
gerne für ein paar sekunden in der
mikrowelle geben falls sie schon
aufbewahrt hat aber guck mal die so
cremig es gebe ich jetzt dazu und dann
wird das richtig gut miteinander
verrührt
[Musik]
den boden jetzt einfach in den
tortenring geben und richtig schön
andrücken ich gebe den boden jetzt bis
zur weiterverarbeitung in den
kühlschrank und bereite schon mal die
gemahlenen haselnüssen vor einfach in
der fettfreien terroristen und
anschließend auch schon die kalte
schlagsahne zusammen mit seiner fest
steigen
das habe ich auch erledigt das
funktioniert wirklich am besten wenn die
sonne ganz frisch aus dem kühlschrank
kommt ich mache jetzt direkt weiter mit
einem handmixer brauche ich jetzt auch
die aufsätze gar nicht saubermachen in
eine schüssel kommen jetzt die
restlichen zutaten für die creme
da habe ich mich für quark entschieden
ich habe heute 20 prozentigen quark
genommen eigentlich ist die fed stufe
egal aber mit magerquark hatte ist oder
hätte ist für mich ein zu sauren
nachgeschmack nimmt auch gerne 40
prozent liegen könnte auch gerne machen
so dazu kommt jetzt nochmals capone oder
zucker und vanille extrakt und dann
verrückt dass nur noch einmal ganz kurz
mit dem handel
[Musik]
zum schluss die gemahlen und gerösteten
haselnüssen auch schon dazu geben dieses
ganz zusammenmixen darf nicht länger
also 10 12 sekunden dauern also wirklich
nur ganz kurz bis es sich verbunden hat
und jetzt macht ihr einfach mit dem teig
sei weiter das problem ist wenn ihr zu
lange rührt dann kommt ja feuchtigkeit
bzw flüssigkeit raus und das ganze
findet nicht mehr so gut jetzt nehmen
wir uns die steif geschlagene sahne und
heben die vorsichtig mit dem teig
schaber unter
[Musik]
die schokocreme kommt jetzt auf dem
boden wird glatt verstrichen und dann
müssen wir geduldig sein in die torte
kommt für mindestens drei stunden in den
kühlschrank damit die creme einfach
schön fest werden kann man könnte jetzt
auch im vorfeld noch mehr seine fest
reintun aber dieses wenige sagen fest
und dann die komponenten quark
mascarpone und sahne in verbindung mit
der zeit macht einfach eine richtig
schöne creme am ende und das warten
lohnt sich ihr könnt doch gerne am
vortag vorbereiten
sobald es dann schön gekühlt ist machen
wir weiter mit dem abschluss dafür mache
ich jetzt einen schönen gruß aus sahne
und vor mich kuvertüre die sahne könnt
ihr entweder in der mikrowelle oder auf
dem herd erwerben
ganz wichtig damit es euch gelingt ist
dass sie das nicht auf kochen also nicht
hochkochen macht diese wirklich nur
erwärmt werden das hat auch nur den
zweck damit die vollmilch kuvertüre
darin schmelzen kann das mache ich jetzt
was das alles gut verbinden und dann
warte ich auch nochmal so acht bis zehn
minuten damit es nicht ganz heiß auf den
kalten kuchen kommen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich den bus auch noch mal
zehn minuten abkühlen lassen ich hab die
torte dafür einfach in den kühlschrank
gegeben dann geht's schneller und jetzt
muss ich das ganze transferieren auf
meine rote tortenplatte und dafür nehme
ich mir einfach so ein skateboard da
vorsichtig und runter und dann kommt die
hier oben drauf und damit wir uns jetzt
auch die ränder gleich nicht weg reißen
und ganz vorsichtig mit der torte
umgehen nehme ich mir anschließend dem
backform löser war hier einmal am rand
entlang mit dem tortenring ab und dann
bekomme ich persönlich noch mit choco
fresh mit haselnuss kern und meta system
[Musik]
fertig ist die choco fresh torte ich
finde sie doch richtig fresh aus also
macht sie unbedingt nach und wenn wir es
ausprobiert ab kommt zurück zum video
und schreibt nur euer feedback hier
unten in die kommentare
ansonsten findet ihr wie immer alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben auch hier unten in
der video beschreibung ich verabschiede
mich an der stelle und wünsche euch noch
einen wunderschönen tag bis zum nächsten
gipfel
[Musik]
nein